esta situación pues viene a
concretar o de alguna manera
demostrar los temores que tenía la
comunidad Europea de que Rusia a pesar
de de su dicho pues han estado
utilizando el suministro de gas como una
arma más en esta en este conflicto que
tiene en contra de Ucrania y de manera
indirecta con el grupo europeo Santiago
esto ocurre precisamente cuando países
europeos están promoviendo medidas que
buscan poner topes a los precios del
petróleo del gas ruso que futuro le ve a
este intento sobre todo teniendo en
cuenta las distintas capacidades no que
tiene cada país para enfrentar esta
crisis
justo excelente planteamiento que hace
Santiago Aquí hay una cuestión bastante
importante esta situación no esta
decisión que que trae Rusia consigo a
través de gas from viene a raíz de que
según el consejo de reguladores
energéticos europeos se tiene ya poco
más del 80% de las reservas en capacidad
completadas por parte de los países de
la comunidad esto representa que cada
vez está haciendo un aseguramiento para
este próximo invierno Además de que ya
se están trabajando opciones de gas
natural licuado así como reforzamiento
del mix energético en los países de la
comunidad Así que esto viene Pues a
reforzar la idea o esta teoría de que
Rusia está utilizando esto como un
mecanismo de este de de coacción con la
finalidad de de buscar un convencimiento
de la comunidad Europea y desistan de su
apoyo occidental hacia Ucrania y esta
situación bastante importante dado que
ya se está comenzando a ver a los países
menos presionados a los países de la
comunidad menos presionados en el ámbito
energético para el siguiente invierno
ahora visto esto desde el lado de Rusia
No qué costos tiene para
Moscú que ve por supuesto reducido su
suministro de gas
definitivamente esta situación viene a
afectar de manera sustancial al
circulante ruso es decir a las formas en
que tiene el país para
financiarse Y obtener liquidez y esto
también lo viene a grabarse con esta
reunión de del g7 reciente que fue
reciente en la semana pasada en donde
también están poniendo un tope a los
precios de hidrocarburos rusos es decir
al petróleo ruso en el cual Pues también
se busca frenar este este esta búsqueda
de liquidez por parte del Estado ruso
vaya del lado de Rusia es una situación
bastante preocupante en donde al parecer
la guerra financiera y la guerra
comercial pues está comenzando a
perderla y aquí es donde empieza a verse
el el verdadero el verdadero potencial
de la comunidad europea como un bloque
económico y político bastante Sólido y
que bueno pueden revertir cualquier tipo
de decisiones erróneas que hayan tenido
en el pasado en busca de un suministro
seguro de gas y están teniendo la
oportunidad de reconfigurar sus sistemas
y sus mixes energéticos